hi I'm Amanda Russo aka Maori unicorn
and I'm an offensive security engineer
and this is hacking support this Twitter
user cloud opening ass at this point
hackers know everything there is to know
about every one of us why do we need
passwords now why keep going to the gym
if you're gonna die anyways passwords
are kind of a necessary evil and hackers
really don't know everything about you
it all depends if you put that
information out there on the Internet
Congrats I know what a white hat is I
know what a black hat is what is a Red
Hat angry hacker
I don't think I've heard the term red
hat hacker before when you're a white
hat hacker you have for good a lot of
people in the security industry are
white hat hackers and then for the cyber
criminals they we call them black hats
there's also this other term called grey
hat where they could be a IT admin
during the day while moonlight as a
black hat during the night hacker for
life ass maurer unicorn how do you even
begin learning and exceeding in this
field I'm trying to become a penetration
tester need inspiration so a pen tester
is kind of like an attacker that goes
and checks all of the external ports any
openings within someones network but if
you really want to be a penetration
tester there's a lot of content out on
the web right now courses workshops they
even have events at a conferences where
you can meet other people in the field
you can find a mentor learn from them
they would point you in the right
direction I feel like the hacker culture
is pretty open and diverse so there's a
lot of content out there malware is the
worst
what is this purpose other than wasting
my time usually malware is going after
money and if anything you're considered
collateral damage when Maur is delivered
they're usually just spraying that all
the malware too many people as possible
so it may not be intended for you
I think of malware as like a fashion
trend you know there's different malware
every season every quarter and you have
to stay in fashion and I'm trying all
the time when you think about older
malware that you Soaker a couple years
ago sometimes it comes back in fashion
this Twitter user name is Jessica Alba
is an interesting choice for hacking
how do hackers decide who they're going
to target Jessica Alba's a beautiful
woman and she's also celebrity so she
sounds like a great shiny object for
cyber criminals to go after but a lot of
them have different motivations that
could include money is probably the
biggest one another one would be
reputation it would be like haha I
hacked this person it could be
information kind of like corporate
espionage and then we have destruction
which is kind of rare basically it is
they try to destroy all the systems to
put that company out of business
Kylie Minaj asks why do they make the
login process for your student loan aid
so difficult and tedious if some hackers
want to break into my account and pay
off all my student loans please don't
make it difficult for them you all are
gonna ruin this for me let them run wild
in there
Kylie these hackers are not going to go
and pay off your debt if anything they
were going to go into the system to pay
off their tuition so a lot of these
controls are in place to hinder hackers
like that to get into your account it's
an unfortunate thing to do but you know
it's necessary axel blazing ass speaking
of what is even the point of these bot
accounts that follow you but well that's
it no messaging or anything no spam just
follow like sake it's done well these
accounts are doing something that may
not pertain to you what we call it
account aging so what that means is
they're trying to bypass a lot of
automated detection from social media
that they have in place to look for fake
accounts and so by tweeting or messaging
or making any type of action they're
trying to bypass the Texan to look more
like a legitimate account this Twitter
user Andrew Chiqui asks what will they
think of next is there anything that has
been courted in the last decade that
hackers haven't found a vulnerability
can do some damage if you think about
your fridge at home being able to
connect to the Wi-Fi or your pressure
cooker being able to connect to the app
on your phone a lot of these devices are
developed in a way where they're looking
for the lowest possible cost of
manufacturing so when they get to the
security part it's kind of like an
afterthought so until things change
we're gonna still have these problems
with IOT
Twitter users sift Basque Maori unicorn
what should my first step be in the
bugging should I just get a file in a
book and start doing the best way is to
just jump right in
think about it as riding a bike it takes
time it takes practice but eventually
you'll get it there's a different
debugger for every operating system but
they're not easy to learn unless you
start you know just doing it yourself
and training yourself and practicing
like I don't remember every single
command in the Bogert I have to use a
cheat sheet Twitter user storm wolf my
awesome boss says that I can request to
change my job title to whatever I want
it to be in our company profile
obviously safe for work could anything
random like Pokemon hacker or
cybersecurity wizard what do you guys
think it should be well I can see you
just said obviously safer work so I
think you shouldn't just name yourself
safe forward this Twitter user sub-8 you
ass your Smart TV and your video
streaming apps are collecting and
sharing tons of data just because it can
how long before we can start having
embedded cameras that malware's triggers
surreptitiously I have unfortunate news
for you this has been happening - six
years and it's going to continue to
happen so too late for you Allison eight
two seven one eight six eight five
that's a mouthful why do you hate C
sharp and his handle looks like a bot I
don't hate C sharp C sharp hates me the
only one of you asks why can't hackers
do anything useful like leak Taylor's
recordings of babe and better man
grow up hackers if you don't already
know Taylor Swift has an alter ego that
we call Swift on security and she's
considered a security Pro in the cyber
security industry so no one actually
wants to hack her but if you're in the
know and who do you know who that is
then you know who it is
this Twitter user zero pone asks can we
stop calling people who DDoS hackers
Journal's why the hell do you even call
them hackers to begin with looking for
legitimate answers as I'm confused as
hell let me set the record straight
there's a difference between hacker and
a cyber criminal so if we were to refer
to the bad guys I would rather prefer to
call them a cyber criminal there's a lot
of people in the security industry that
considered themselves hackers there's a
lot of people that hack for good
WM Ramadan asked morena corn I have a
simple yet daunting question why do you
use a Mac for your security work I mean
a lot of people argue the fact that
Linux is a way to go in terms of
security Mac is similar to Linux think
about two different brands of cars they
look different on the outside but they
could be sharing the same chassis
underneath there's not a lot of malware
out there for Mac and Linux I mean it's
there but you know currently most of
them ours on Windows the bishop or Josh
Harris 25 what is the point of spam
emails are they profiting from it what
do they gain from spending random
unnecessary emails when people send out
spam emails they're sending it to
thousands and thousands of targets say
you had a million emails sent out and
they're requesting $1 these cyber
criminals are expecting that 1% will
actually bite a lot of these cyber
criminals will treat this as a business
so it becomes very lucrative for them
cyber tooth marry and corn if you would
or create a time line for an incident
what would it look like just curious
because your design skills are cray-cray
well a lot of people don't know this but
before I got into computer science
I was actually pursuing a degree in
graphic design so a lot of it from my
time doing that carries over into my
work back when I used to work at the
Department of Defense I used to create
these 3d videos to describe different
type of network layouts I didn't know 3d
design at the time so I spent a weekend
taught myself and the next day started
you know making content if you can make
things look nice and be able to
communicate the actual abstract content
it helps don't look ass
yeah but bad pickup lines and phishing
really any different low effort easy
reuse and rarely do you get a success I
really think fishing is more effective
than saying a pick-up line I've Vlad
Dalvi I studied one a car i case in NHS
hospital a disaster seemed totally
preventable why didn't they patch were
they lazy stupid in the case of this
incident a hospital in the UK was
under a ransomware attack it happened
because they didn't upgrade their
servers or their computers and this is
the whole reason why upgrading is really
important but when you think about it
some of these infrastructures like
hospital or a power plant a lot of them
cannot experience any downtime so when
you do do an upgrade you have to shut
down the systems for a little while
Hiero 7:33 asks as someone who doesn't
work in InfoSec what are red and blue
team I'm assuming red are the pen
testers these terms actually come from
the military where they would perform
military operations they have a team
that acts as the red team doing the
attacks and the blue team serves as
defense team similar to what we have in
cybersecurity and that the red team is
attacking the blue team's systems the
whole point of what the red team does is
to enumerate holes within a network we
want to find the holes before the bad
actors do you think of it like we're
sparring partners so we're really not
there to antagonize a blue team or
anything like that we really want to
work together with the blue team roots
asylum hacker kid interviewed his mom
about what it's like to build a career
in InfoSec something Def Con parents
often think about how do we inspire kids
to go into the space and see it for the
fun and challenge that it is well when I
was young I had no idea I was gonna be
in this job I actually had to know that
this job existed in order to actually go
into it if there was a chance that at a
career fair you would have someone who
gets the hack for a living I think that
would be a really cool thing to have you
have to have the correct mentality to be
in this industry the whole hacker
mentality is creatively thinking outside
the box solving a problem that's out of
the standards or norms of what how it's
supposed to execute if we kind of use
that type of mentality in some of the
content or workshops or anything that we
reach out to these kids with it will
kind of inspire them to want to solve
problems in this field this Twitter user
ARF Ness asks why do stock image hackers
exclusively wear ski masks and hoodies
well I think the photographer was going
for a feel of an actual robber criminal
but there is a reason
to wear something on your face they're
trying to hide their face from cameras
or any type of identifier that will
tribute them to a crime and why they're
wearing hoodies I can imagine that some
of these serving rooms are super cold
they need to cover their ears if you
don't already know you know some of us
actually dress like this to work and I
actually have a ski mask for all of my
outfits and let me put it on for you
guys and it's not complete without the
glasses we're good to go it's time to
hack this has been hacking a support
with a manner or so you guys stay safe
out there